in public education there are a lot of
different ideas about what the purpose
of education is if you ask any student
or even a lot of parents
they immediately start talking about
getting a job
security for the future and kids will
say the purpose of education is to get
rich that sounds good on the surface but
what it yields is an education system
that asks sixth graders to figure out
what they're gonna be when they grow up
and so you get schools where
teachers are there to sort of supervise
and
guide but not to teach directly as a
mother
i wanted
much more than that for my children i
didn't want them to go through an
education system
i wanted them to be
educated
if you come to one of the hillsdale
classical schools you will see
all kinds of things going on that just
don't go on in public schools anymore
[Music]
in the hillsdale classical school we are
training the minds and the hearts of our
students
we're training them to think well and
we're training them to love the right
things
we want our students to learn to be
virtuous people and we want them to be
knowledgeable people and we want them to
spend their lives pursuing the good even
if we produce students who don't know
everything if we produce students who
have the disposition to continue
learning and teaching themselves and
pursuing knowledge
then we've done a good job
way to go good morning
[Music]
sometimes people think that classical
education is really elite and fancy and
only for a certain group of students
and that's not true if you look at the
history of education in this country you
see that a couple generations ago
everyone was learning to diagram
sentences everyone was learning cursive
lots of people were learning latin
there's a difference of course between
the great minds that we study and
ourselves
but it's not that the great minds are
the only ones who can understand these
things we can too the difference is the
great minds are the ones who first saw
it
i could never do the things newton did i
could never do the things einstein did i
could never discover those but once
they've been discovered i can read what
they've done and i can follow it and i
can understand it and everybody can it
doesn't take
a super high sat score to be able to
study latin classical education cannot
be exclusive
and it cannot be elitist
if classical education does what it says
it does which is
educate the person in terms of human
nature
then by virtue of attempting to perfect
human nature it is for everyone
when i started
honestly reading listening and meeting
people who were involved in
the renewal classical education the word
that came to me
was that they were whole
something was integrated in their minds
and their souls that was different from
pretty much everybody i was meeting
what classical education has
really done for me is and i think the
point of classical education is to make
someone who's
a well-rounded and good person who's
really you know educated holistically we
don't just think oh i'm a math person or
i'm a literature person
it's everyone is going to learn math and
everyone learns literature because those
are things that you you need it's like
giving a child good nutritious food
instead of
just candy that tastes good
and so they develop an appetite for
things that are truly good
and beautiful
and true
i think definitely the public school
education is purely utilitarian they
teach you to be kind of brains on sticks
is what i like to say they don't teach
the whole person they just teach you
know the facts and this is this is this
is training for your future this is
training for jobs so when i did come to
this school i was surprised that we were
you know the school had virtues and we
were they were developing our character
we were learning about different levels
of friendship and i i'd never learned
that before it has taught me a lot just
that
education is not just for the sake of a
job education is learning for the sake
of learning
i didn't know going into hillsdale
really what classical education was and
so i felt behind
you know a lot of the students there
already had been reading
aristotle and plato and all of these
great thinkers
and i hadn't read them and so i didn't
know
what a lot of those things meant
and what it meant to
have an education like this
asking these big questions and these
really important books has led me to
you know think about my future and in
doing so i think that i want to continue
pursuing these big questions and things
that i care about and so i think when i
go to college i want to pick a college
that really cares about the
formation of the soul and not just you
know
a job training so a student who walks
all the way through and receives a
classical education by the time they're
graduating from a school like ours
i think they really have wisdom well
beyond their age
in part because they've become in a
sense the things that they've beheld
and what we see is
people who aren't confident without
being arrogant
people who are well spoken
and who think that their lives have a
purpose
and who feel equipped to
begin pursuing happiness in the best way
[Music]
[Music]
we have parents who come in all the time
thinking oh my goodness wow this is
amazing what they are doing can my child
do this too and i look at them and i say
absolutely i teach here and i teach in
general because i want to see the kids
learn and watching them having that
moment of understanding and of clarity
that makes everything worth it i think
my hope for them is
they would be
more fully human when they leave here
i hope that these schools will remind
people that these classical methods
are worth pursuing because
they work
and that as a country
our future depends
on
raising a generation of young people
who
know how to think and read
and write and spend their lives pursuing
the right things and loving the right
things
[Music]
you